très déçu en outre mer on a été
on a voté marine le pen donc macro tu
n'es pas le bienvenu
non
[Musique]
et
là aujourd'hui on va vivre encore cinq
années de calvaire et ça va être encore
pire et les gens s'attendent à quoi les
gens s'attendent à quoi aujourd'hui moi
j'ai voté marine le pen et j'en ai marre
j'en ai marre de vent ce qui s'est passé
les français n'ont plus de mémoire il
est temps qu'on se réveille aujourd'hui
je suis très déçu on a des problèmes
d'eau moi je suis une soignante j'arrive
chez des clients et il n'y a pas d'eau
pour la vie les gens
on a fait appel à st et rien n'a été
entendu le pouvoir d'achat a diminué
on n'a aucune réponse sur ça donc c'est
normal que la population réagisse et moi
je vous dis sincèrement que les
résultats du vote de l'outre-mer en tout
cas ne m'a pas du tout surpris
[Musique]
je pense que les guadeloupéens ont voulu
sanctionner
m'a comparé à pois ou pas ces décisions
par acquis social mais se trouve pas que
c'est elle c'était le moment ni n'avait
aucun intérêt à voter le pen surtout
nous les antillais donc je suis dans
l'incompréhension
[Musique]